i used to complain about work all the
time the long hours the disrespect for
my boss getting home exhausted aching
and sunburned i worked in construction a
lifetime ago i'd give anything to go
back to that now what's that they always
say you don't know what you've got until
it's gone maybe i deserve the hand i've
been dealt i haven't been a good person
i don't play well with others there was
an argument with my foreman when i got a
little too heated i just couldn't reign
in my temper the hammer i'd been using
all day was still in my hand but i
digress i used to build things with my
hands but i'm in a different line of
work now if you can call it work that
would imply i get paid i clock in every
morning and i get to go home afterward i
don't i'm a prisoner really a glorified
lab rat and property of the all-powerful
scp foundation i've been here about
three weeks and everyone always says
d-classes like us last about a month
here so uh clock is ticking down to zero
for me i haven't had to do anything too
dangerous yet but like i said it's just
a matter of time i'm sitting in my cell
the same windowless box i've spent every
day for the past three weeks when a god
bursts in and grabs me by the arm what's
going on i ask but he ignores me of
course i make conversation with a lab
rat better not to think of us as human
at all he yanks me down the hall opens
the door and shows me inside there's
several other d-class in there already
and they're staring at something in the
corner that i can't quite make out i
start to turn around and to take a look
at the rest of the room but a voice
comes over the loudspeaker cold and
clinical look at the statue in the
corner do not take your eyes off it well
when a disembodied voice at the scp
foundation tells you to look at
something you better do it so i look
it's a sculpture made from concrete and
rebar it looks pretty harmless but i've
heard enough screams through the walls
to know they don't keep too many
harmless things caged up here whatever
this thing really is i don't want to
know what it'll do to me when my back is
turned i stare at it unblinking feeling
my eyes burn and tear up from the dry
air and concentration i'm scared to
close my eyes for even a second
determined not to be the first one in
here to break but something out there
has other plans for me for us i hear a
warbling sound like a motor struggling
to start the sudden crash of thunder
outside and then the room goes black for
a second i think i've gone blind but
then i hear the other guys screaming the
yelling of scientists behind the wall
somehow the power's gone out i i can't
see anything but i can hear the sound of
stone scraping against itself the snap
of breaking bones the thud of a lint
body slumping over to the floor the room
comes into focus again as the backup
generator kicks in and fills the space
with weak fluorescent light but but
something's different something's wrong
the statue in the corner is gone the
other two men are on the floor heads
twisted around backwards and the door is
standing wide open is this a trap trick
of some kind if i run out that door will
a guard be waiting there for me i don't
know but whatever might happen to me if
i try can't be any worse than what will
happen if i stay right here through the
wall i hear the sickening snapping sound
again a corpse thudding to the ground
they didn't plan this something in their
experiment went horribly wrong for them
maybe just maybe it went right for me i
don't give a second thought i'm out the
door running through the dimly lit halls
through the maze of identical corridors
in search of some kind of exit all
around me there's chaos gods firing
their weapons at inhuman shapes that i
catch a brief glimpse of as i run past
scientists yelling for help people going
as fast as they can towards danger and
away from it i'm so caught up in it all
i don't even notice when i run right
into a woman in the white lab coat
knocking us both to the ground i
scrambled to my feet and look her with
wide eyes waiting for her to turn me in
to call the guards but she doesn't uh
i'm so sorry i stammer she holds out a
hand gesturing for me to help her to a
feed so so i do watch her step there she
says with annoying smile i can't help
but notice how beautiful she is
twinkling brown eyes and thick black
hair then i spot them tucked under her
hair but unmistakable she has a pair of
fox ears on top of her head it hits me
in rapid succession than all the things
about this woman that don't look quite
right her unusually long nails too sharp
and pointed for lab work the feral glint
in her eyes that halting cadence of a
voice this woman is not an employee of
the scp foundation she's doing the same
thing i am taking advantage of the
situation to try to escape i'll uh be
more careful from now on ma'am i say she
winks and turned down the hall i can see
a tail poking out beneath the bottom of
a lab coat safe travels i call after her
she laughs a dangerous sound like she's
not the one who needs to worry about
staying safe and i wonder what might
have happened if i had caught her in a
worse mood good thing my mom taught me
my manners now which way should i go
from here should i follow the woman i
get the feeling she doesn't want you
company and i prefer to stay on the good
side as i'm thinking it through i hear a
small popping sound behind me like a
vacuum in the air being filled all of a
sudden i spin around there's a guy
standing there oil in there as you
please blonde hair green eyes wearing
jeans and a t-shirt that says mothman
fan club in red lettuce this guy looks
pretty out of place more the type you'd
see browsing a comic book store but
after my prior strange encounter
i don't know not to assume anything hey
man what's going on he asked me i stayed
back not sure what to say what i miss he
continues i feel like i was gone for
ages um
i just stood to our collective
surroundings the sound of alarms blamed
and voices crying out for backup the
inhuman shrieks of creatures being
forced back into the cells there's a
lot going on huh yeah seems like it the
guy size you wouldn't happen to know how
to get out of here would you i ask
hopefully he shakes his head sorry i
don't really come and go through the
door here i guess i'll just go back to
my room until things calm down a bit you
want anything i got a mini fridge in
there he offers
no thanks suit yourself man he shoves
his hands back in his pockets and walks
away whistling a tune to himself if he's
this unfazed by teleporting into the
middle of a complete mad house i don't
even want to know what kind of stuff
he's seen nice enough kid though
probably better company than anyone or
anything else in this place if i'm not
going to take him up on his offer though
i should keep moving before someone
notices i'm not where i'm supposed to be
around the corner just in time to see
another body drop i whirl around looking
for that horrible statue but i don't see
it instead i see what looks like a man
dressed in all black wearing a mask in
the shape of a bird's face with a
long-pointed beak he's carrying like an
old school doctor's bag and he's bending
down to inspect the body of the god that
just keeled over i should keep running i
should do something but i can't look
away the man in black pulls a syringe
full of thick green liquid from his bag
and injects it into the corpse to my
heart the body begins to move thrashing
around hands opening and closing
grasping for something it sits up
reanimated but wrong its eyes are
bulging and vacant like a goldfish its
mouth hangs slack as this zombie climbs
to his feet the figure in all black
turns to look at me i shine him from
beneath his mask hello my good fellow
how are you feeling today he calls to me
his voice polished and polite i'm fine i
shout mind shaking my chest tight the
doctor tilts his head to the side
thoughtfully you don't look well my
friend perhaps you could allow me to
examine you the zombie shuffles towards
me and the doctor opens his bag there is
this pestilence raging through this land
you see i'm not gonna stick around to
find out what that exam might look like
or what he might try to do in the
service of curing me no banks i don't
have health insurance that is all i can
think to say as i turn and run the way
back i came i still have no idea where
an exit might be how i might get out of
here it looks the same one long stretch
of tile and white i guess a place like
the foundation isn't gonna have red neon
signs telling you how to escape but this
place can't go on forever can it i'm
starting to have my doubts before i can
get too lost in my own hopelessness the
biggest man i've ever seen comes
lumbering down the hall toward me i work
with some pretty big guys in
construction massive behemoths who could
carry steel beams like they were pool
noodles but this man something else
entirely he's gotta be like what eight
feet tall the fists that they look like
they could crush my skull in one hit i
better get out of this monster's way if
i know what's good for me but as he
passes me he waves and gives me a great
big friendly if unnaturally wide smile
beautiful day isn't it you bellows in
that booming french accent the voice
with his other hand he picks his teeth
with something white a closer look
reveals to be a shot of bone i have to
imagine it's human his lips are stained
dark with blood you look lost can i help
you with something a helpful people
eater
what a guy i keep my distance but decide
to try my luck you wouldn't uh happen to
know where the exit is they say he beams
at me thrilled by my question i'm so
glad you asked his dismay
he points down a hall to the left just
follows that hollows if you're down and
takes the only right that should get you
where you're going thanks
give him a wave back as i head that way
as i go i can hear the giant singing
opera to himself something italian
reminds me of a record my grandma used
to play a long time ago maybe this will
get me free maybe it won't but it's more
information than i had a second ago
might as well give it a shot if i make
it through this i'm going to be in the
best shape of my life from all the
running i've done today maybe i'll try
to do a marathon or maybe i shouldn't
get ahead of myself there's no one else
down this particular hall at least no
one that i can see i slow my pace to a
steady walk keeping my eyes and ears
alert for any potential threats so far
so good reach the other side of the hall
and take a right turn and nothing just
the wall that giant son of a gun lied to
me i guess that's what i get for asking
a cannibal for directions i guess i'm
lucky he just misled me instead of
having me for dessert i'm about to play
my next move when i feel something nudge
against the back of my leg i turn and
there's what i can only describe as a
blob just a large mass of orange slime
wrapped around my legs making a friendly
high-pitched gurgle they should be
suspicious of it after everything i've
seen but i'm not i just get the feeling
that this thing has my best interest in
heart hey buddy they padded slimy
surface and it ripples delightedly
making another gurgling sound it's kind
of cute honestly i smell the scent of
freshly brewed coffee one of my favorite
smells in the world
i haven't had a decent cup in years all
of a sudden i feel this overwhelming
sense of happiness hope even if it's
foolish to think so i honestly believe
that everything's gonna be all right
this strange little friendly slime has
given me the strength to carry on i wish
i had the plushie version of this thing
there's a sun tickling sensation along
my legs and i laugh pushing the slime
away gently
hey stop that
he coos apologetically and bumps itself
against me like a stray dog asking for
scratches behind the ears i wonder for a
second if i could take this thing with
me but what would i even feed it what
kind of life could i give a domesticated
slime creature better to leave it with
the people who know how to care for it
even if they're mad scientists i give it
another pat then head on my way the sly
mooses off in the opposite direction i
have to find more new friends i imagine
i had no idea there was anything nice in
here with everything horrible i've seen
today warms my cold heart just a little
bit it's strange been walking for a
while and i haven't seen anyone else
it's eerily quiet over here i can i
can't hear a thing except for that alarm
in the distance not sure when all the
screaming went quiet or where all the
gods went it's peaceful but i have to
admit it's eerie there's no way it's
this easy there's no way i'll just be
able to walk out of here life doesn't
work like that especially not here my
eyes dot around watching for any
potential danger as i go maybe all the
action is on the other side of the
facility maybe something broke out of
containment that's so big so dangerous
that all hands are on deck to contain it
or maybe they're all dead and i'm next
nah nah i i shouldn't think like that i
feel the hairs on the back of my neck
prickle i have that paranoid feeling of
being watched like eyes burning into me
a glance behind me but there's no one
there i stopped walking but i don't hear
any other footsteps calm down there's no
one here with you i tell myself just
keep moving i turn my eyes back to the
path ahead of me and i freeze what was
that i saw something just for a second
something long thin spindly like a stick
bug but much much bigger but look for it
it's gone but i know that i saw it but
this place has now driven me insane
glance to the side and there it is again
for a split second so fast i could
almost convince myself i imagined it if
i were at home or walking down an
ordinary street i might think i i had
but i'm not anywhere ordinary and a
slender monster that can hide my
peripheral vision only to be spotted for
a millisecond at a time that seems par
for the course in a place like this
there
i just saw it again it's like wants me
to know it's here but that'll i'll never
be able to pin it down
i'm not playing mind games with a
monster forget it i'll keep moving
another flash of the creatures closer
than it was before whatever you don't
scare me i say out loud i'm lying but i
hope it can't tell if i just play cool
maybe this thing will get bored and find
someone else to menace i've been running
for a long time now but my heart is
still pounding i can taste metal in the
back of my throat suddenly all the
sounds from before our back the gunfire
the screen and the shriek of alarms made
my way back to the action one sound
drowns out all the rest a deafening raw
animalistic and powerful and hateful it
reminds me of a dinosaur in a movie but
with the power that makes my bones
rattle and my teeth chatter the roar is
followed by more screaming in a massive
crash the crunch of wood and stone
there's another roar more distant than
before wait whatever made that sound it
just broke out i better left a pretty
big hole in its wake i follow the sound
and find exactly what i hope i would a
massive opening in the wall and the
sweet feeling of a breeze coming through
i couldn't find the next but this thing
just made one for me i don't waste any
more time i make a break for it dancing
around rubble and pools of corrosive
acid and sprinting into the nearby
forest i'm ducking under branches
dotting around trees and i run until i'm
seeing spots my lungs are gasping for
air i'll know how far i'll make it if
there's a town nearby or any kind of
shelter but i promise one thing if i
survive i'm gonna be a better person
i'll get it right this time i'll earn my
second chance at life now go check out
how to work at the scp foundation
explained and revenge of d-class ghosts
of
scp-4973 dead men walking for more look
at the lives and deaths of scp
foundation d class